[Música]
salud en directo américa de frases 24 me
acompaña a esta nueva semana del
programa como siempre más romeros a la
encargada de esta sección de salud mal
usted se imagina que aquí en colombia ya
nos quiten el tapado casa por siempre
pues la verdad es que no es tan
simbólico de la pandemia que cuesta
hacerse la idea de una vida sin el
tapabocas no ojalá que sea pronto sobre
todo en espacios cerrados a lo mejor mar
le digo a esto porque muchos países
están decidiendo eliminar el tapaboca
obligatorio y porque lo están haciendo
bueno pues como bien decías a medida que
avanza la pandemia hay muchos países que
están levantando estas restricciones
primero en interiores luego en
exteriores por ejemplo en francia ya se
eliminó la obligatoriedad en ambos
espacios igual que en españa a partir
del próximo miércoles en brasil es la
misma situación y por ejemplo en
colombia pues todavía se tiene que usar
en espacios interiores en general son
países de gobiernos de países donde la
incidencia del cobi realmente ha bajado
hay una baja transmisión del virus y por
lo tanto se decide pues tomar esta
decisión también en muchos lugares de
europa de cara al verano que está
llegando la primavera que se está
viviendo ahora esas decisiones provocan
reacciones muy distintas desde alegría
hasta preocupaciones escuchamos lo que
decían en francia al respecto
si podemos respirar es verdaderamente un
gran placer nos encontramos de nuevo
como antes y podemos intercambiar más
allá de la mirada podemos ver las
sonrisas duela se llevan de linesur yo
escuché su comodidad
tengo una comorbilidad tengo más de 60
años
aunque esté vacunado eso no me impide
intentar protegerme a mí ya los otros
que
existen en el mar pero como decidir
estos y seguir llevando el tapabocas o
no pues primero vamos a repasar cómo es
que se contagia al coach para entender
también qué efectos tienen los tapabocas
al respecto no recordemos que este virus
se puede transmitir tanto a través de
gotículas que son como pequeñas gotas de
saliva que expulsamos al hablar al
cantar al gritar al correr y luego
también como aerosoles que en verdad es
la vía principal de contagio nos lo
podemos imaginar como si fuera el humo
del tabaco que en exteriores se dispersa
mientras que en interiores sino
ventilamos se puede concentrar y a
medida que estamos expuestos a ese humo
no en este caso estos aerosoles
contagiados pues nos podemos exponer
cada vez más al riesgo también de
contagiarnos es precisamente por eso que
primero se suele levantar las
mascarillas la previsión la
obligatoriedad perdón de mascarillas en
el exterior
en los interiores que es donde hay más
reticencia y por eso es que la
ventilación es un elemento clave y
también pues hablando de la situación
como decías epidemiológica de los países
no en un momento de alta
transmisibilidad sería bastante
irresponsable levantar los tapabocas
land mientras que en momentos de baja
transmisibilidad pues es un poquito más
al tranquilo realmente ha sido eficaz el
uso de tapabocas mar para para contener
y prevenir esta pandemia claro pues es
una pregunta clave para tomar este tipo
de decisiones no saber si nos ha
funcionado o no nos ha funcionado porque
acional es la decisión es por un lado
individual no como de saber pues
exponerse a qué riesgos no que estamos
dispuestos y por otro lado también es
una decisión conjunta social porque
nuestras decisiones individuales van a
tener consecuencias sobre los demás
empezando por esta parte social los
datos agregados de varios estudios
publicados en la revista científica bien
ya vieron que realmente al inicio de la
pandemia sobre todo las mascarillas
ayudaron a reducir como ven en más de un
45 por ciento la mortalidad en más de
200 países donde se recogieron estos
datos y también se redujo
aproximadamente un 22 por ciento la
transmisión del virus aunque es difícil
saber exactamente no como como
funcionado sabemos que efectivamente si
han tenido una con una unas
consecuencias positivas en ayudarnos al
inicio de la pandemia pero precisamente
por eso es importante recordar que son
datos previos a las vacunas y a las
oleadas por infecciones también que
hacen que esto pueda ser un poco
distinto en el momento actual pero pues
es importante tener en cuenta que son
efectivos y que juegan un papel muy
relevante en evitar pues rebajar la
emergencia sanitaria la sobrecarga de
los hospitales así es marc seguimos
hablando de los tapabocas y la
efectividad de ellos digamos unos
mejores que otros en el 95 famoso los de
tela o sea qué pasa con esto la
efectividad de los tapabocas pues es que
la verdad son todos distintos y tienen
consecuencias también distintas los
datos publicados por el centro de
control y prevención de enfermedades de
eeuu
la verdad muestran y aquí en este caso
gráfica 2 por el diario del país
muestran cuánto tiempo una persona
necesita para contagiarse en un espacio
cerrado y sin ventilarse según el tipo
de mascarilla que lleve que vemos que
las mascarillas de esas de tela aumentan
algo la protección pero no mucho la
quirúrgica si las dos lo llevan puede
protegerte hasta una hora y la máxima
protección es la n 95 porque protege
pues de todo tipo de partículas
importante también decir que las de 95
son las que más te protegen a ti mismo
se el miedo es tu contagiarte es
importante llevar por ejemplo ese tipo
de mascarilla y no una quirúrgica para
finalizar motivos que se tienen en
cuenta entonces es gobiernos para poner
o quitar los tapabocas el epidemiológico
para empezar no la transmisión la
incidencia del virus en ese momento
tener en cuenta que si eso puede
aumentar pues podríamos volver a ver
obligatoriedad de las mascarillas pero
también no un motivo político no al
final como decíamos la mascarilla ha
sido un símbolo de la pandemia dejar de
llevarla parece un símbolo de que se
termina la pandemia cuando pues la
verdad es que todavía estamos lejos de
eso y pues desde aquí la recomendación
de ir con mucho cuidado con eso también
desde los gobiernos porque es un tema
muy emocional no los que tienen prisa
por dejar atrás la pandemia tienen prisa
por levantarse los tapabocas los que en
cambio pues les angustia eso deciden se
angustian también cuando el resto de
personas no lo llevan y ellos son los
únicos entonces pues es un problema
social una persona con una mascarilla en
una habitación de 20 no sirve para nada
y socialmente es como lo tenemos que
resolver yo soy uno de esos de los
primeros grupos que está de prisa porque
lo que no entendemos son dos años más de
dos años ryan pero bueno hay que hacerle
caso igual a las autoridades y cuando se
quiten interiores pues ya quitarnos el
tapaboca mar muchísimas gracias nos ve
mañana con más salud pasamos a saludar
precisamente para hablar de la pandemia
nuestro segundo invitado el día